[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de Paf
au sommaire nous allons parler du
dossier des retraites en décision
d'expliquer un peu les enjeux de la de
la réforme on parlera aussi d'une
affaire qui a divisé la presse les
Français les médias et puis les
intellectuels c'est l'affaire
Houellebecq et ses propos tenus dans le
débat qu'il avait eu avec Michel Onfray
sur les musulmans et puis plein de
petits sujets d'actualité enfin qui est
quand même intéressant c'est est-ce
qu'il faut que Noël regrette démissionne
de son poste de président à la
Fédération française de football
pour parler de tous ces sujets Véronique
Jérôme bonjour Patrice vous êtes Polito
économiste vous êtes maître de
conférence à diversité de Paris Saclay
et le site que vous avez fourré avec
votre mari
à chaque fois j'en fais la parce qu'il
est absolument exceptionnel mais je
dirais pourquoi dans quelques instants
parce que Didier bécher avec nous
bonjour
vous êtes ancien député de la première
circonscription des Yvelines de
Versailles
lrem à l'époque ça s'appelait elle rêve
Renaissance maintenant et maintenant on
va descendre
donc je dis juste un mot sur le sur le
site c'est vrai que ce site qui n'est
pas fondé sur les sondages mais sur des
études sur le comportement des électeurs
avait prévu à la virgule près au mois de
janvier les résultats du premier tour
des présidentielles alors que les
sondages donnaient encore Zemmour au
deuxième tour à ce moment-là donc voilà
Jean-Charles la joie dit bonjour bonjour
ça va bien très bien toujours les
éditeurs toujours éditeur et toujours
préoccupé par
certaines désaffections des gens pour
les librairies en ce moment donc voilà
qui vont un peu moins acheter de livres
donc on a fait un bon mois de décembre
mais c'est vrai que c'est quand même un
peu troublant c'est plus on n'est pas
sur une
peur dépenses je pense que les gens
n'arrêtent pas montre leur faire
craindre tout et n'importe quoi qu'ils
aient ou pas de l'argent on dit qu'ils
en plus et puis voilà donc c'est un peu
un peu gênant enfin on continue à faire
des bons livres et qu'ils se vendent
donc ça va mais mais l'avenir est pas
rose quand même voilà peut-être moi
aussi
ils vont tous se voir Avatar alors ça
c'est déjà très bien ils reviennent au
cinéma
Geoffrey Meyer bonjour bonjour Patrice
comment ça va très bien merci vous êtes
toujours avocat au Barreau de Versailles
et ça va plaire à Jean-Charles j'aime
beaucoup les livres voilà voilà et on
sait ce secrétaire de la Confédération
secrétaire de la Conférence du stage
voilà alors
il y a plusieurs sujets qu'on va aborder
dont ce serpent de mer qui s'appelle des
retraites qui a une sorte de casse-tête
on va parler d'abord du casse-tête des
retraites
[Musique]
alors c'est difficile de tout comprendre
dans ce système parce qu'on a des
informations très
différentes selon les uns selon les
autres d'abord sur l'état de notre
système de retraite c'est vrai que vous
avez une moitié d'économie existe qui
vous disent ben non c'est pas il y a pas
grand chose il y a pas de déficit
terrible et puis tout va se redresser
tout seul en 2070 d'autres qui disent
bah si et notamment le corps qui dit
risque d'y voir déficites dans les
années 2030 2035
qui peut nous résumer Véronique
peut-être si on alors pour résumer on
peut pas résumer en quelques mots une
situation qui est non seulement complexe
mais en même temps qui est suspendu aux
prévisions et aux hypothèses qu'on fait
sur les perspectives d'avenir c'est un
peu loin et plus l'avenir est éloigné
plus le degré d'incertitude est fort et
donc moi on a d'informations pour
prendre les meilleurs décisions possible
j'ai même pas les bonnes décisions mais
au moins les meilleures décisions
possible donc ce fait étant posé on fait
souvent tout le monde s'appuie très
généralement sur les les références du
corps mais le problème c'est que le
corps mais aussi des hypothèses et dans
les hypothèses pour résumer globalement
on regarde la situation de huit quatre
types donc du privé du public donc il y
a 8 cas qui sont regardés au plus près
pour l'individu au plan macroéconomique
il y a il y a deux conventions avec
EPR ou ecpr équilibre permanent des
régimes ou efforts de l'État constant
donc déjà ces deux façons de résoudre
techniquement financièrement les choses
qui va amener à conclure que dans le cas
de l'effort permanent de l'État on a
dans trois cas sur quatre on peut
retrouver un équilibre assez court terme
et dans l'autre cas on aura de
l'équilibre que dans un cas sur quatre
mais tout ceci ne vaut que sous les
hypothèses de productivité du travail
productivité horaire moyenne du travail
donc elle peut être la croissance de
taux de chômage etc le corps nous dit au
lieu d'en mettre deux je vais en mettre
4 et donc on a des scénarios qui sont
très très éloignés les uns des autres et
donc tout ceci pour résumer et pour
arrêter les les aspects trop techniques
consiste à dire la solution elle est
dans la croissance on a besoin de
croissance elle est dans garder les gens
au travail peut-être et faire en sorte
que à partir de 55 ans on ne se pose pas
la question lorsqu'on est une entreprise
de savoir si on ne pourrait pas
embaucher quelqu'un de plus jeune parce
que je ne le problème voilà et le
problème alors il y a aussi cet aspect
là la pression qui est une vraie
discrimination travail et puis l'autre
sujet pour terminer si on regarde un
petit peu comment les choses sont
perçues il y a bien sûr le gouvernement
qui est dans son rôle et qui nous dit je
veux préserver alors je veux préserver
le système par répartition sa forme
d'emblée ça ferme pardon d'emblée la
porte à une hypothèse une possibilité de
capitalisation
ne veut parler c'est quelque chose qui
oblige l'état puisqu'on dit je veux
conserver le système par répartition
l'État est dans sa logique mais ça
signifie que d'emblée l'État ne veut pas
alléger son implication en autorisant
une partie par capitalisation
les futurs retraités prendre
l'initiative d'aller chercher un une
assurance à fond de conscient qui soit
gérée collectivement ou individuellement
comme le fond d'autres pays qui sont
beaucoup mieux classés que nous dans les
les analyses qu'on peut faire sur
pratiquement les trois cas les deux
tiers de la population mondiale sont 44
pays la France est 22e il y a que le
confort des retraités qui passent pour
le reste financement etc tout le monde
nous dit ce n'est pas la bonne solution
et l'autre l'autre question je voulais
en terminerai c'est quel est le ressenti
de la population si on en croit les
sondages même si le sondage n'est pas un
substitut à la à la réflexion comme
disait Bachelard si on en croit les
sondages que l'on voit c'est que il y a
un ambiguïté les Français sont contre
l'allongement pour une réforme
globalement au gros
ils sont contre aujourd'hui ils sont à
50% 54% contre chez Harris Interactive
ils étaient pour à 59% en septembre donc
là aussi des choses ont évolué et quand
on parle de l'âge c'est épidermique
personne je veux accepter de travailler
plus longtemps parce qu'il y a une forme
de désacralie de famille on pourrait
revenir mais désacralisation du travail
et une forme peut-être de leur les mots
peut-être trop fort mais de
sacralisation du loisir peut-être que le
confinement nous a aidé à apprécier
finalement le télétravail mais ça aussi
c'est un faux débat c'est un faux débat
Didier mes chers vous avez beaucoup
travaillé pendant le
précédent texte et sur le premier cas
d'Emmanuel Macron pourquoi après il y a
eu quand même pas mal de réformes
réforme Fillon après il faut me Sarkozy
qui passe à 62 ans la réforme Touraine
qui passe à 43 à nuités pourquoi il faut
une nouvelle réforme il y a deux sujets
permanents qu'on a beaucoup de mal à
régler c'est pas propre à ce
gouvernement mais c'est propre à tout le
gouvernement
désigné qui était forte qui persiste
sur la pénibilité sur le travail des
femmes qui peuvent être hachées sur les
travailleurs précaires donc ce sujet là
il est toujours en termes de solidarité
nationale toujours très présent et puis
le déficit du système alors on est passé
rapidement comme ça moi j'aimerais bien
justement un tout petit étage parce que
cette discussion elle va aussi
s'inscrire dans un contexte social où on
parle aussi de la santé des difficultés
de nos soignants donc juste vous donner
comme ça deux chiffres qui me semblent
intéressants le budget social en France
c'est 800 milliards
d'accord donc c'est le plus la plus
grosse dépense donc c'est là c'est la
plus grosse dépense de l'État et c'est
le pays la France au monde qui dépense
le plus dans le social donc quand on dit
le social c'est la branche famille la
sécurité sociale et les retraites les
retraites dans ces 800 milliards pèsent
pour plus de la moitié 15% du PIB donc
on voit déjà que dans notre budget
social quand on commence à parler on
parle beaucoup en ce moment de la
situation de la santé de la
revalorisation du personnel de santé
donc on voit bien que ça s'inscrit dans
un contexte qui est compliqué et je le
dis comme ça rapidement parce que
j'avais souvent l'habitude de dire ça le
budget de l'État c'est un camembert à
portion construite connu et qui n'évolue
pas c'est pas une entreprise l'état on
va pas faire des parts de marché
supplémentaires vendre des trucs en plus
donc si on donne à un moment donné
beaucoup plus sur le secteur de la santé
ou c'est le secteur de la famille il
faut que la branche retraite qui pèse
lourd soit équilibrée
vous disiez en introduction oui
finalement le déficit est pas peut-être
pas si important etc moi c'est pareil
c'est en plus l'équation est très simple
en 12 milliards
12 milliards je crois partir de 2027
dans le dans le corps donc 12 milliards
chaque année pas uniquement 12 milliards
c'est 12 milliards chaque année 12
milliards ça représente exactement c'est
le même chiffre de ce qui était dépensé
pour le Ségur de la santé donc pour
financer en 2020 en 2021 et en 2022
l'augmentation des personnels de santé
donc a été négocié avec les syndicats du
secteur de la santé au moment du Ségur
ça coûte 12 milliards donc on voit bien
que on peut pas s'asseoir si on veut
avoir une protection supplémentaire si
on veut 1200 euros de pension minimale
pour l'ensemble des personnes qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie il faut le
financer donc on peut pas se permettre
de perdre 12 milliards et puis un
système par répartition par définition
il doit être équilibré sinon on bascule
en solidarité nationale c'est-à-dire que
c'est l'impôt qui finalement va payer le
déficit ça devient très bancal et on va
revenir à des discussions est-ce qu'il
faut pas mettre du privé dedans etc ce
en quoi alors là c'est moi à titre
personnel je crois qu'on a un système
qui est en tout cas équitable et qui
vise à ce que toutes les personnes qui
ont et qui ont travaillé à un moment
donné soient traité de la même manière
si on met de la capitalisation à mon
Dieu d'ailleurs ce qui existe déjà enfin
rien d'interdit à personne de faire de
la capitalisation
dans les entreprises qui ont des plans
d'épargne entreprise aujourd'hui et qui
ont l'intéressement de la participation
ou de la prime Macron peuvent tout à
fait le verser sur leur la panoplie
d'épargne salariale qui est prévu à ce
moment-là il y a énormément de
dispositifs retraite donc en fait rien
n'empêche de le faire peut-être par
contre on reparlera peut-être de
pédagogie peut-être qu'il y a besoin de
refaire de la pédagogie sur l'ensemble
de ces dispositifs qui sont peut-être
pas bien connus de l'ensemble des
salariés français est-ce que ce que vous
dites au fond c'est et c'est peut-être
le discours qui aurait pu avoir le le
gouvernement peut-être plus clairement
au fond la réforme de retraite c'est pas
si compliqué que ça à mener et ça
rapporte de l'argent qui serait mieux
dépensé ailleurs encore une fois
si on veut mieux rémunérer les
personnels de santé les aides et des
aides-soignants etc il faut bien de
l'argent et donc on peut le trouver là
il y a le financement du système de
retraite et il y a aussi peut-être un
peu d'argent qu'on peut dépenser mieux
ailleurs bien sûr et et pour contrer
j'entends certains partis politiques qui
disent oui mais l'État veut accélérer le
dispositif donc en allant plus vite sur
sur les 43 annuités aller plus vite à 43
que ce que la réforme toi ne prévoyait
et donc ils vont ils vont engranger de
l'argent pour faire autre chose mais non
non on est dans le budget de la Sécurité
sociale le budget du social dont je
parlais tout à l'heure donc là dépense
elle sera inscrite dans ce cadre là donc
oui peut-être que sur la branche famille
peut-être que sur la branche santé pour
les soignants il pourra il pourra y
avoir des choses plus intéressantes mais
encore une fois ne serait-ce que pour
financer le 1200 euros c'est-à-dire 85%
du SMIC pour toutes les personnes qui
ont travaillé toute leur vie
il va bien falloir trouver l'argent
quelque part mieux rémunérer les
retraites des femmes qui ont par
définition des carrières hachées etc ce
qui avait été déjà prévu et qui sera
probablement repris en amendement dans
le texte précédent il va bien falloir de
l'argent pour le faire donc si on veut
dans ce camembert encore une fois
portion connue apparemment il faut bien
qu'il n'accélération donc une rentrée
d'argent plus importante plus vite que
ce qui était prévu je crois en réalité
moi je vais être parfaitement dans les
clous avec ce que vous avez dit Monsieur
le Député alors là où moi je me félicite
c'est que on a parlé de l'augmentation
du budget de la santé le budget de la
justice aussi a augmenté sur les deux
dernières années depuis la mandature la
prise de fonction d'Eric Dupond-Moretti
les budgets ont augmenté donc nécessaire
solidarité entre avocat
pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout
absolument aucune forme de contraternité
non mais c'est vrai que le budget de la
justice pour la première fois augmenter
depuis longtemps il était absolument
nécessaire qu'il le soit et là aussi à
nouveau lorsque début dieux augmentent
vous lisez monsieur le député
ipso facto il faut qu'on le finance
quelque part donc c'est vrai que cette
réforme des retraites elle m'apparaît
quand même importante pour que on puisse
permettre à la fin aux générations
futures alors déjà premièrement de
pouvoir partir dans des bonnes
conditions et puis également de faire en
sorte que les
services les services publics les
services publics de l'éducation de la
Justice de la santé fonctionne
correctement mais à nouveau et ça c'est
vous qui lisez tout à l'heure et vous
aussi vous lisez monsieur le député je
pense qu'il y a un effort de pédagogie
qui doit être fait de la part du
gouvernement pour pouvoir expliquer
toutes ces choses là pourquoi c'est
nécessaire et pourquoi voilà avec je
pense deux grandes problématiques qui
sont lesquelles il va le gouvernement va
devoir se positionner c'est premièrement
alors certes on repousse l'âge de départ
en retraite mais comment on intègre la
pénibilité
et deuxièmement et ça c'est vous qui
lisez tout à l'heure c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de l'emploi des seniors
puisque l'emploi des seniors alors soit
coûte cher soit on sait que à partir
d'un certain âge
qui sont encore dans l'emploi exactement
30 % qui sont en dehors alors
comment est-ce que on permet que
l'emploi des seniors soit maintenu j'ai
vu que a priori il y avait des questions
de pénalité financière qui devaient
apparaître sur les entreprises qui
n'emploient pas suffisamment de seniors
là encore comment est-ce que ça va être
calibré comment est-ce que ça va être
agencé je pense que il y aura beaucoup
il y aura des explications qui devront
être faites et un vrai effort de
pédagogie qui devra être réalisé de la
part du gouvernement
essentiel c'est un peu comme on est en
France on serait dans un pays
anglo-saxon ou même on serait en
Allemagne on aurait quand je dis en
Allemagne c'est au sens avec une culture
de la négociation sociale différentes de
celle de la France même si on est un
pays de négociation sociale on aurait
des positions en fait on comprendrait
qu'il faut que les seniors restent plus
longtemps dans l'entreprise pour y lire
le système et donc on le ferait mais en
France c'est comme l'égalité
professionnelle c'est-à-dire que tout le
monde intellectuellement comprend le
sujet il faut accélérer qui a des femmes
il y a pas de raison qui est pas autant
de femmes que d'hommes au poste de
direction etc donc ça on a dit ça
pendant des années et puis ça a vraiment
changé parce qu'il y a eu des lois et
puisqu'on est arrivé à l'index et je
pense que pour les seniors enfin moi en
tout cas je suis très très favorable à
ce sujet on mettra en place cette index
d’analyse de comment les entreprises se
comportent avec leur pyramide des âges
tout simplement et on peut construire
une pénalité sur la masse salariale
exactement de la même manière que sur
l'index de l'égalité
le patronat le Medef commence déjà à
dire oulala c'est trop compliqué on n'a
pas le temps mais c'est totalement faux
quand vous vous faites votre base de
données sociales tous les mois dans
votre négociation avec les syndicats
vous communiquez ou dans votre bilan
social vous communiquez déjà toutes les
informations donc il y a aucun travail
supplémentaire juste de l'exemplarité
permettra de demander aux entreprises
vous le faites vous payez pas de
pénalité vous n'êtes pas exemplaire et
vous vous séparez de vos Seigneur avant
on vous donne une pénalité voilà c'est
très très simple
qui va mal passer auprès des chefs
d'entreprise parce que mettez-vous la
place du chef d'entreprise c'est encore
à nouveau la carotte et le bâton c'est
encore l'état qui va ajouter encore à la
réglementation de réglementation
supplémentaire pour quelque chose qui
pourrait être tout à fait naturel si on
considérait que le Seigneur représente
un capital humain important une
expérience et que cette expérience on a
envie d'en profiter on n'est pas obligé
de considérer que alors ça veut dire
finalement c'est une bataille
intergénérationnelle parce qu'on va se
dire c'est je prends des guillemets
parce que je trouve ça un peu insultant
mais c'est les jeunes contre les vieux
la personne qui va rester un peu plus
longtemps pour certains vont prendre la
place d'un jeune diplômé qui n'a pas eu
d'expérience mais aujourd'hui avec
l'apprentissage qui est véritablement
une réussite dans ce pays à tous les
niveaux c'est pas simplement l'apprenti
boulanger on le voit aussi à
l'université des mam2 qui trouve assez
rapidement un emploi je pense que un peu
de pédagogie sur la relation
intergénérationnelle serait peut-être
plus efficace et moins contraignante que
le fait de dire à nouveau aux
entreprises on va vérifier on va
sanctionner parce que
responsables
psychologique c'est à dire que pendant
des années il y avait ce système
sur-utilisé par les entreprises de
mettre les gens au chômage pendant deux
ou trois ans en fin de soi-disant en fin
de carrière en disant vous êtes au
chômage vous avez deux ou trois années
de chômage possible on vous demandera
même pas de chercher du boulot après
vous allez passer en très retraite et
après vous prendrez votre retraite
c'était une facilité énorme parce que
c'était qu'elle est sur un donc vous
pouvez virer des gens vers 55 56 ans
Dieu vous allez venir
maintenant si le laisse de la retraite
est repoussé à 64 65 ans ça repousse
aussi ce seuil psychologiquement et on
dit pas on va peut-être dire bah ok au
lieu d'essayer de virer les gens à 55 on
va essayer de les virer 58 59 donc déjà
ça et du gouvernement on sait que
l'aspect de l'âge légal des entreprises
à employer
de pédagogique etc il y a quand même
au-delà de tous les chiffres que vous
dites et que vous évoquez tous avec
beaucoup de brio etc mais le truc qui me
paraît quand même le plus simple c'est
quand même de dire à tout le monde et
que tout le monde réalise que on vit
tous de plus en plus vieux et que voilà
il y a juste un liquide objectif
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé parce
que là il y a une il y a un décalage
entre la femme cadre et l'homme ouvrier
il y a 10 ans d'écart l'espérance de vie
donc là d'où l'importance de la
pénibilité comme le désert ouvrier je
veux dire
globalement tout le monde vit plus
longtemps donc le temps le temps ou le
on est obligé de payer les retraites aux
gens augmente considérablement et tant
mieux je suis ravi qu'on vit tous
beaucoup plus vieux mais ça me paraît
assez simple comme discours même pour
des gens qui ont pas quand même des
capacités de réflexion évidemment
là c'est simple il y a moins de jeunes
on fait on fait aussi moins d'enfants
donc il y a une pyramide non mais ça va
extrêmement simple que tout le monde
peut comprendre et si on se basait déjà
là-dessus de discussion serait que c'est
quand même un peu simplifié le problème
de la démographie c'est que ça prend du
temps faire des enfants aujourd'hui ce
ne sera pas des actifs on pense que ça
se rétablit parce que là il est les
baby-boomer avec une grande force enfin
une grande note de naissance et puis
après ça se rétablit un petit peu donc
c'est plus simple un mot justement
toujours sur la pédagogie il y a deux il
y a deux grandes écoles il y a ceux qui
disent c'est la réforme Touraine il faut
augmenter le nombre d'annuités et par
exemple Laurent Berger l'univers de la
CFDT est d'accord avec ça il est
d'accord avec la réforme Touraine et
puis ceux qui disent il faut un âge
légal 65 visiblement ça sera 64 ans
quelle différence entre les deux
réformes
pourquoi il y en a une qui est plus
efficace que l'autre quand on parle de
l'âge on regarde l'aspect durée à la
retraite quand on parle des annuités on
regarde des espèces cotisations et on
garde aspect financier et le problème
c'est que là encore si on évalue une
réforme on ne regardant qu'un paramètre
on peut pas apprécier la réforme la
réforme est faite de de considération
non seulement sur tous les aspects et en
même temps d'interaction c'est à dire
que chaque élément va interagir dans un
environnement macroéconomique et donc
une réforme va avoir des modifications
de comportement donc micro-économiques
les individus vont appréhender le
travail différemment dans un
environnement qui lui aussi est en
mouvement et là pour dire pour dire un
peu les choses on a quand même un
problème la pédagogie vient peut-être du
fait que on est au sortir alors
certainement que la crise covid le
confinement le télétravail ont habitué
où ont appris aux individus l'expérience
d'un travail différent et donc le fait
de travailler d'être en télétravail à
donner de nouvelles habitudes de vie on
aurait pu croire que
soit dénoncer comme étant prioritaire
soit elle est acceptée avec une
concertation ça c'est dans les sondages
c'est comme ça que ça ressort donc on
veut bien de la réforme disent les gens
mais on veut de la concertation donc ils
sentent qu'il y a une nécessité d'un
réforme mais le problème c'est qu'ils
ont un comportement un peu ce qu'on
appelle en économie public de freerider
c'est-à-dire que ils sont un peu
opportunistes ils veulent bien que on
impose des contraintes aux autres à
condition que ça profite à la situation
personnelle à travailler plus donc là
c'est un souci et ce souci
personnellement je le relie à cette
situation où il y a non seulement ce
qu'on appelle le burn out donc tout le
monde connaît le fait que on est
désincité ou on est on est des impliqué
mais il y a aussi le quai le quiting
c'est à dire le le fait que les agents
en font moins parce que la situation
macroéconomique l'inflation qui ruine le
pouvoir d'achat ou qui va leur ruiner
dans certaines catégories c'est déjà on
le sent déjà les agents se disent bah
finalement mon pouvoir d'achat
s'amenuise mais on me demande toujours
d'en faire soit toujours autant voire
même plus parce que toutes ces éviter ou
on chronomètre le temps on revient
finalement à des périodes oubliées mais
toutes ces activités je veux pas citer
non mais où les délais sont importants
où on demande une tâche à exécuter dans
une heure et ça il y a de plus en plus
de je crois que c'est le tiers des gens
au travail qui ont ces contraintes leur
fait prendre des distances avec le
travail et on cet aspect de et bien je
vais faire je vais faire le minimum
c'est à dire ce pourquoi je pense que je
suis rémunéré donc ce rapport au travail
est important c'est pourquoi on peut pas
dire à quelqu'un rester plus longtemps
parce que quand on aime son job et ça il
y a encore je j'imagine et je l'espère
des gens qui qui aiment ce qu'ils font
mais visiblement ils sont plus
peut-être des métiers
les mêmes mais c'est même pas je pense
qu'on peut pas catégoriser
même un métier qui pourrait sembler ardu
l'artisan qui a des conséquences qui est
soumis aux contraintes climatiques etc
aime son métier il y a pas de raison de
de je pense que c'est même pas une
question c'est pas le travail en lui
c'est l'approche que l'on a dû
travailler de ce qui la porte
intellectuellement
les aides-soignantes etc qui sont mal
payés qui sont difficiles etc
très important sur lesquels vous trouvez
pas tellement de de gens qui sont qui
veulent qui veulent les exercer
en ce moment dans une société où il ne
se passe pas une journée sans qu'on
entende va des gens qui s'expriment sur
la pénibilité supposée de leur travail
sur le fait que c'est compliqué à chaque
reportage on dit ah oui le type va être
obligé de bien faire son son travail
mais heureusement c'est quand même c'est
le minimum de base de bien faire son
boulot le boulot pour lequel on est payé
et on a l'impression que maintenant
c'est une performance on dit alors lui
telle personne qu'il soit infirmier en
quelques heures ah bah oui tu es obligé
de soigner les médecins quelle belle
affaire oui pour ensuite
la pénibilité de notre travail parce que
comme les trains sont en retard les gens
sont très en colère
conduire un TGV la pénibilité je ne sais
pas où elle est enfin je veux dire faut
arrêter quand on voit en plus quand vous
disiez très justement on dévalorise
l'idée de travail mais que je crois je
sais plus c'est la RATP ils vont payer
les gens pour au-dessus en plus de leur
salaire pour être sûr qu'ils vont venir
très fort
sur la sur la défiance vis-à-vis des
employeurs c'est c'est beaucoup plus
large que que les retraites mais ça en
dit long en fait sur la responsabilité
qui pèse sur les employeurs pour
recruter pour garder les seniors enfin
voilà il y a une nécessité pour les
employeurs de se ressaisir de l'ensemble
de ces sujets il y a une ambiguïté qui
demeure et ça on a fait en termes de
pédagogie qui est toujours compliqué on
l'a vu sur les cotisations chômage c'est
qu'en fait beaucoup de Français disent
j'ai cotisé pour
parce qu'on paye des cotisations et en
fait non puisque on l'explique très bien
en fait
on n'a pas engrangé on n'a pas fait une
épargne personnelle donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui est difficile il s'est
passé la même chose sur la forme du
chômage c'est-à-dire que on a supprimé
en 2017 en 2018 les cotisations de
sécurité sociale et de d'assurance
chômage donc salariat et on continue à
entendre le discours oui mais j'ai
cotisé au chômage donc j'ai droit au
chômage non c'est la solidarité
nationale maintenant qui paye le chômage
c'est pas les cotisations salariés donc
je pense qu'il faut y faire attention et
puis après il y a quand même un chiffre
qui est intéressant parce que on voit ce
débat sur 64 65 ans aujourd'hui la
moyenne de départ c'est 63,7 donc on
voit bien que finalement cette histoire
de 64 c'est pas un truc totalement
démentiel puisque c'est la réalité de ce
qui est vécu si on si on ajoute les
départs anticipés parce que c'est pareil
quand on n'est pas dans un métier où il
y a évidemment des départs anticipés
avec de la pénibilité on a toujours
l'impression que c'est les autres qui en
bénéficient si on compte
ce que sont les départs anticipés
aujourd'hui on a une moyenne de départ à
62,5 ou 6 quelque chose comme ça donc on
voit bien qu'il y a quand même une part
importante de la population française
qui aujourd'hui part déjà beaucoup plus
tôt que dans il faut je pense qu'il faut
remettre aussi les choses bien sûr mais
il y a déjà une partie importante de la
population et il faut arriver à
conserver c'est un des enjeux de cette
réforme arrivé à conserver un taux
important de gens qui sont dans des
métiers pénibles et qui vont pouvoir
partir avant 64 ans
par exemple si on prend la CFDT qui est
quand même un syndicat réformiste bon
Laurent Berger dit par exemple quelqu'un
qui a commencé à travailler très tôt à
18 ans si on passe à 64 ans ça lui fait
en effet
calculé mais 46 ans enfin de cotisation
à peu près au lieu de alors que mais
et Elisabeth borne dit non mais on
dépassera pas les 43 ans donc c'est bien
que
sous-entendu la pénibilité ou le fait de
rentrer très tôt dans la vie active ça
va être pris en compte c'est toute la
question de est-ce qu'on a commencé à
travailler avant avant 20 ans ou pas
qu'il y a une histoire autour de 20 ans
donc tous les gens qui vont avoir
commencé à travailler avant 20 ans vont
bénéficier d'un dispositif ou
effectivement ils pourront partir avant
64 ans
est-ce que je vais avoir une retraite à
taux plein ou pas c'est ça aussi ou le
1200 euros devient très important je
vous rappelle enfin c'est surtout les
gens qui nous écoutent c'est aujourd'hui
pour avoir une retraite à taux plein
souvent on est vraiment obligé d'aller
jusqu'à 67 ans et et on voit bien que
quand on a eu soit du travail haché
parce qu'on est majoritairement une
femme soit parce qu'on a eu des métiers
précaires j'en sais rien des accidents
peu importe beaucoup beaucoup de gens
sont obligés d'aller jusqu'à 67 pour
avoir une retraite à taux plein et donc
ça ces éléments-là vont pas changer donc
attention c'est un peu l'ordre c'est un
peu comme la retraite c'est son sang ça
veut pas dire que tout le monde va
partir à 64 attention si vous voulez
avoir votre traite à taux plein vous
serez obligé d'attendre le fameux 67 ans
qui est la loi aujourd'hui parce que ce
sera changé de cotisations
contre cette allongement de la retraite
vont enfin eux prendre leur retraite
avec avec leurs
enfants
qui dégage Martine Aubry Mélenchon enfin
tous ces gens qui donnent des leçons en
permanence mais qu'est-ce qu'ils font
encore là quand je vais pouvoir le faire
c'est la différence par rapport à un
travail mais non mais c'est les citoyens
qui choisissent non mais là c'est plus
c'est une question de si vous si vous
vous en voulez pas enfin je veux dire
très méprisant de la part des hommes
politiques qui consiste à dire alors
pour le peuple il était fatigué puis
c'est les boulots qui font il faut qu'il
s'arrête mais nous on est censé être
plus intelligent on est on est une sorte
de casque nous on peut travailler
jusqu'à 90 ans
un abonnement dans lequel les hommes
politiques de gauche doivent partir
nécessairement avantage avant 45 ans
de travail fin des députés 70 ans mais
le problème c'est que vous pouvez
manquer aussi un moment donné de
personne qui vont se présenter on
imaginons pas
des élections pour objet les hommes
politiques à prendre leur retraite je
voudrais juste que les gens qui sont
contre l'allongement de la
façon voilà
mais que le grec soit président à 80
balais je trouve ça très bien voilà
un mot alors peut-être politique
maintenant parce que c'est il y a aussi
ce ce cet aspect là on a beaucoup parlé
du 49-3 pour le vote du budget enfin
dans les premiers mois de de
l'exercice de fonctions previe sur
Elisabeth borne là on a vu les matériaux
d'érections
en gros les propositions qui vont être
faites par le gouvernement donc
visiblement le une majorité à
l'Assemblée ça semble
très probable
non vous êtes l'expérience tant que ça
fait parce que le nombre de gens qui
vous donnent qui vous embrassent et vous
font des accolades en disant oui et puis
après une fois qu'on est sur le terrain
et que ça Tang et que les gens sont dans
la rue et que finalement tiens il y a
peut-être un intérêt politique tu vois
que ce type vient juste d'être élu donc
il faut qu'il rassemble un peu cette
droite conservatrice donc peut-être que
si ça t'engue un peu il va peut-être
trouver que il faut s'acheminer non non
je pense que personne n'est dupe enfin
camarade député à l'Assemblée ils vont
ils vont jouer leur partition ils vont
essayer d'avoir le maximum d'amendements
possibles pour que cette réforme soit
juste tant mieux si les républicains et
d'autres enfin tant mieux si c'est voté
largement sinon vous savez c'est comme
le budget à un moment donné la France
peut pas être bloquée quand le débat a
eu lieu et et là pardonnez-moi mais la
concertation Olivier dussobe Elisabeth
borne on est depuis l'été que personne
ne dise qu'il y a pas de concertation
parce que ça discute et Olivier du sol
est vraiment enfin un ministre du
Travail qui pour le coup va pas faire la
publicité de l'ensemble des discussions
qu'il a avec les part réseaux sociaux il
fait son travail il rencontre il
consulte etc donc la concertation elle a
lieu elle a lieu avec les partenaires
donc on débat dans l'assemblée c'est le
jeu démocratique et il est nécessaire et
indispensable chacun s'exprime et
malheureusement quand à un moment donné
on est au bout du bout et que on va
discuter juste parce qu'on fait de la
procédure ce qui s'est passé pour le
budget c'est à dire que les oppositions
font de la procédure par moment donné on
dégaine quelque chose qui est prévu qui
est le 49-3 et voilà sur la majorité
politique c'est pas c'est pas gagné et
ça dépend alors ça c'est très
intéressant parce que ce que vous dites
parce que
ça dépendra peut-être de la rue et c'est
vrai qu'il va y avoir un front comme un
syndical et on va voir si ce front
commun
aboutit à une mobilisation populaire ou
pas oui puis un moment vous allez avoir
des élections sénatoriales au mois de
septembre qui sont essentiels pour les
républicains parce que c'est quand même
le creuset les élus locaux c'est LE
CREUSET le plus important pour les
républicains donc si ça commence à
attendre bien sûr et si ça commence je
ne sais pas ce qui va se passer moi j'ai
pas de boule de cristal mais je veux
juste pour dire attention ce n'est pas
dans un couloir d'un érection en plus
donc moi personnellement
mais je suis plus député donc j'ai la
chance voilà de m'exprimer en simple
citoyen non moi j'ai pas confiance en
tout cas après la réalité c'est que
l'assemblée il y a pas de majorité
absolue donc le gouvernement est obligé
de proposer ce qui est plutôt plutôt pas
mal
candidats ont proposé la logement
compliqué de dire
voilà
plus plus à gauche maintenant que la
gauche c'est à dire que quand j'entends
Eric cioti parler avec tellement
d'entrains des 1200 euros je vous avoue
que les bras montants un tout petit peu
quoi dire que on croyez que c'est
l'herbe qui ont inventé le le social
pour les gens en difficulté
électorat des des plus de 60 ans qui ont
voté quand même majoritairement Emmanuel
Macron dès la première élection euh qui
avait quand même une origine et l'air
donc là on voit cela on voit aussi bah
finalement dans le programme de Valérie
Pécresse il y avait aussi l'histoire de
la retraite 65 ans donc là elle est
quand même pris en tenaille dans et pour
être pris dans une
difficulté certainement à défendre
quelque chose qui avait été initialement
dans un programme il y a une forme de il
y a une forme de triangulation pardon du
terme mais il y a une forme de
triangulation de la part d'Emmanuel
Macron qui a su assez facilement et
assez habilement quand une triangulation
on s'accapare une partie du programme de
de l'opposition et puis aussi et je
pense que là aussi on ne peut non plus
là aussi on ne veut pas donner de je
dirais de de prévisions c'est quel est
l'état des syndicats parce que pour
l'instant ils font des des événements
enfin des effets d'annonce en disant on
est unitaire on va se réunir on va
décider
de position
qu'on constate actuellement c'est quand
même une forme de d'hybridation des
manifestations c'est à dire que quand
les les médecins
un doublement de des honoraires quand
les fameux contrôleur c'est pas les
contrôleurs les agents de bord de la
SNCF sont allés dans la rue ils le sont
allés en s'organisant soit sur les
réseaux sociaux enfin le syndicat est
entretien un peu la voilà donc la
faillite c'est peut-être un mot un peu
fort des syndicats dans l'affaire de la
SNCF
de confiance ils étaient à 46 % 70 de
confiance on est à 31 aujourd'hui et
d'ailleurs la perte de confiance dans
dans les organisations syndicales et
dans les organisations politiques aussi
bien évidemment et dans le patronat
aussi
qui est beaucoup voté pour les élections
syndicales
depuis 25 ans donc c'est pas nouveau en
fait le débordement par la base c'est un
vrai sujet parce que les réseaux sociaux
parce que plein de raisons qui font que
les syndicats qui peuvent être plus ou
moins représentatifs d'une entreprise à
l'autre vont se retrouver déborder mais
enfin
c'est pareil si les syndicats
réformistes en fait sont sont seuls
isolés dans la négociation les seuls à
négocier j'ai envie de dire on va
essayer de trouver un accord pour avoir
un compromis ça ça rend la situation pas
compliqué c'est à dire que les autres
syndicats ils vont mettre tous les
agents de la SNCF dans la rue en fait ce
qu'ils vont ce qui va bloquer la France
en fait quelque part et c'est un vrai
pouvoir de nuisance alors qu'à côté vous
enfin je veux pas citer la CFDT c'est
très connu évidemment mais vous avez
quand même d'autres syndicats aussi qui
essayent de trouver du compromis et de
faire bien sûr ça des fois dans dans sa
partition le fait aussi ça me semble
être quelque chose qui peut tirer les
syndicats vers le haut genre du sac les
Français ils vont ils vont probablement
mieux comprendre un syndicat qui va
réessayer d'obtenir quelque chose que la
manifestation dans la rue qui
malheureusement enfin la cassé les pieds
à tout le monde mais mais
je suis pas certain que malgré ce France
syndical la mobilisation populaire soit
très forte mais voilà
en ce moment sur les salaires ça c'est
intéressant il y a beaucoup d'entre qui
ont du mal à mobiliser
voilà il y a une négociation sur les
salaires elle aboutit finalement un non
accord avec les organisations syndicales
mais la mobilisation des salariés est
très faible quand ils appellent
parce que la situation économique est
quand même compliqué pour la majorité
des ménages quoi voilà donc
5e position donc on voit bien que la je
vois aussi non pas cela faire
Houellebecq
parce que de la retraite on aura
l'occasion d'en parler alors justement
on va on va parler de cette affaire
Houellebecq
[Musique]
par l'écrivain dans la revue Front
populaire dans son débat avec Michel
Onfray alors on peut peut-être voir les
propos qui ont été
retenus enfin qui ont posé problème
l'une consiste le premier propos conseil
c'est à dire qu'il pourrait y avoir des
Bataclan à l'envers c'est à dire voilà
si jamais des territoires étaient aux
mains désislamistes et puis deuxième
deuxième propos qui fait débat je crois
que le souhait de la population
française de souche comme on dit ce
n'est pas que les musulmans
s'assimilent mais qu'il cesse de les
voler et de les agresser
bon c'est vrai que alors
pour en revenir sur le sur le fond le
recteur de la Mosquée de Paris avait
dans un premier temps dit qu'il allait
porter l'affaire en justice visiblement
il y aura pas de plainte puisqu'ils se
sont rencontrés que Houellebecq est un
peu venu sur ses propos mais bon il ne
reste pas moins qu'il les a tenues et
que ça pose quand même problème
visiblement enfin je ne peux pas nier
que ça c'est évident que ça pose un
problème moi je ne comprends pas le
problème c'est on est dans le
l'expression d'une opinion qui peut
plaire ou pas plaire très bien je vois
pas en quoi le fait d'annoncer une
crainte en disant il y aura des Bataclan
à l'envers je vois pas ce qu'il y a de
raciste là-dedans et d'appel à la haine
raciale
interpréter comme ce qui souhaite alors
c'était peut-être les monts un sens
encore plus quand ils sont écrits je
veux dire c'est extrêmement clair il n'a
pas dit je le souhaite il a dit c'est ce
qui va arriver c'est ce qui craint voilà
bon voilà c'est une ça me paraît tout à
fait légitime d'avoir un certain nombre
de craintes après on peut tout à fait en
débattre et dire que c'est effectivement
faut que ça n'arrivera jamais et c'est
ce qu'effectivement je souhaite que ça
n'arrive jamais mais c'est un dei
d'opinion enfin je veux dire et là
s'enfonce on en est là quoi et quand on
voit en plus parmi tout à l'heure en
introduction de des réactions des
intellectuels je trouve que les
intellectuels dès qu'il s'agit de ce
genre de propos sont d'une discrétion
absolue c'est-à-dire que personne ne
soutient Houellebecq mais même pas sur
le fond de ce qu'il dit mais sur le fait
qu'il est le droit de s'exprimer
sur la liberté d'expression
il y a un vrai débat par rapport à la
liberté d'expression en tout cas sur le
plan juridique la liberté d'expression
c'est le seul droit qui est garanti par
la Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme qui est soumis à une limitation
tous les autres ne le sont pas donc
nécessairement lorsque l'on fait usage
de son de sa liberté d'expression on
doit en accepter que derrière on Vienne
potentiellement contrôler ou remettre
cet usage dont les limites de la liberté
d'expression donc là en l'espèce le
réacteur de la grande mosquée de France
il dit à Houellebecq dans les propos que
vous avez tenus vous avez
potentiellement fait enfin commis un
délit de provocation à la haine envers
les musulmans qui est une limitation de
la liberté d'expression vous pouvez dire
ce que vous voulez mais à partir du
moment où vous tombez dans le giron
d'une infraction comme c'est le cas on
l'espèce alors cette liberté
d'expression elle est contrôlée elle est
réduite maintenant l'autre question
maintenant qu'on peut avoir de fonds sur
un point de vue strictement juridique à
nouveau c'est est-ce que les propos qui
ont été tenus par Michel Houellebecq
dans cet entretien et qui ont été
ensuite retranscrits à l'écrit
sont-ils des une incitation Allen
raciale ou pas ou à la haine envers les
musulmans
alors les musulmans donc des musulmans
si on fait une analyse alors bien
évidemment que ça a pas été porté devant
les tribunaux a priori ça ne saura pas
donc mais si on regarde un petit peu ce
qui a été dit par Michel Houellebecq et
qu'on remet ça sous la loupe et sous le
prisme de cette infraction
il faut croire qu'il est pas totalement
totalement dans ce cadre-là les propos
sont endancieux quand on est Michel
Houellebecq et qu'on est l'écrivain
français
voilà le plus lu dans le monde à mon
avis on doit quand même faire preuve
d'une certaine modération mais si
j'analyse ça mais si j'analie ça sur le
plan strict du droit
l'infraction d'incitation à la fin de
d'incitation à la haine contre les
musulmans elle est très stricte il ne
faut pas qu'il y ait une incitation il
faut pas qu'il y ait une simple
suggestion il faut véritablement et ça
c'est la Cour de cassation qui le dit le
texte et la Cour de cassation il faut
qu'il y ait un appel ou une exhortation
explicite et donc on peut considérer que
dans cette hypothèse là mais je suis à
nouveau hein on va être très clair je
suis strictement dans une analyse
juridique vraiment strictement et
s'il avait fallu que je raisonne en tant
qu'avocat c'est probablement ce que
j'aurais dit maintenant et à nouveau je
rejoins parfaitement les propos vous
allez dire que je suis excessivement
confraternel avec mes semblables mais je
rejoins totalement les propos qui ont
été tenus par Richard Malka dans les
Figaro qui dit lorsqu'on est Michel
Houellebecq et ça rejoint ce que je
disais aussi on doit quand même faire
preuve d'une modération lorsque
il y a quand même un milieu entre
une forme de passivité vis-à-vis de
l'islamisme et une condamnation totale
et là véritablement Michel et la
véritablement Michel Houellebecq
aurait sans doute pu faire preuve d'une
forme de modération
c'est ce qu'on demande à l'intellectuel
ce qu'on demande à quelqu'un qui pense
c'est de penser si c'est pour si vous
voulez que dès que quelqu'un
que ce soit un robinet d'eau tiède et ce
soit des duesp espèce de bruélisme en
disant bah oui j'aime pas la guerre faut
pas faire du mal au bébé phoques etc ok
c'est très bien mais on aura les
intellectuels qu'on mérite je suis
désolé on peut ne pas être d'accord avec
mais il faut pour qu'il ait le droit de
dire ce qu'il veut et justement parce
qu'il est Houellebecq parce qu'il est
Houellebecq c'est tout et si après ça
contrevient la loi il y aura un procès
et si jamais si ça contenait autant que
ça à la loi je pense
je pense que le lecteur de la Mosquée de
Paris jusqu'à la plainte il a dû
regarder et avoir des des avocats qui
qui lui ont dit bon bah ouais peut-être
que ça n'ira pas jusqu'au bout mais
sinon je serais ravi qu'on fasse un
procès à Houellebecq et qu'on puisse en
débattre
on peut on peut en débattre en dehors
mais sinon à part le point
légitimer toutes les théories du Front
national mais dans ce cas-là je veux
dire il faut enfin je dirais il faut
être un visage découvert mais moi j'ai
aucun problème avec la liberté
d'expression ils disent qu'il veut enfin
mais dans ce cas il faut assumer quand
on dit les musulmans
je suis un peu enfin je je vais pas me
mettre la tête dans le sable et faire
semblant qu'il y a aucun problème et qui
a pas des des endroits en France des
quartiers où on s'arme et où les sont en
difficulté mais parlons de la politique
de la ville mettons des échecs comme ça
moi je veux bien qu'on débattre de ça
sans problème mais après c'est pas les
musulmans vous savez si on a un tel
échec de la politique de la ville parce
qu'on a parqué des gens et que les
musulmans à un moment donné des
travailleurs pauvres tout au même
endroit dans les mêmes conditions dans
les mêmes écoles sans aucune mixité etc
mais on a la situation qu'on vit
aujourd'hui je
qui est un sujet d'islamisme donc au
sens politique du terme qui essaye de
servir de la misère des gens oui
certainement mais quand on a un
intellectuel autant écouté autant lu on
peut pas faire semblant que mais ce
qu'on dit ça va pas être su comme une
sorte de bombe ou verser un peu ce que
vous dites parce que est-ce que est-ce
qu'il est pas autant lu parce que
justement cette liberté de parole parce
que là vous dit-il élu faut qu'il
s'arrête de parler mais s'il est s'il
était pas
qui disent je je soutiens les théories
du Front National et je suis un ultra
conservateur qui revendique etc
et puis c'est diabolisation dès qu'on un
discours sur sur l'islam et sur les
musulmans aussitôt
visiblement je suis étonné ah bah ouais
c'est le fonds
facile c'est tellement facile de de
jeter comme ça un truc bon bah alors la
réalité qui disent je vois pas pourquoi
le fait de craindre mais c'est pas de la
clan à l'enversaire
du rassemblement national exigeant en
quoi cette crainte et d'extrême droite
encore une fois la crainte moi je
heureusement on est on est sur un
plateau on en débat et enfin qui
permettent de le faire et la politique
et l'Assemblée nationale enfin voilà les
élus locaux sur le terrain mais tant
mieux qu'on en débatte bref encore une
fois c'est toujours reçu ouais c'est
donc on voit bien c'est une phrase on la
sort et il sait très bien l'effet qui va
avoir une c'est très bien pourtant ou
alors c'est là l'exigence qu'on aurait
pu avoir vis-à-vis de Houellebecq c'est
qu'en réalité et c'est là où je vous
rejoins pas du tout sur le fait de dire
il faut l'empêcher de parler ou si on
lance si on le contraint à une une forme
de trader ça veut dire qu'on enlève
toutes formes d'intellectualité de
subversivité dans son propos là je vous
rejoins pas du tout en réalité ce que
l'on aurait pu exiger de Houellebecq
c'est qu'ils disent totalement la même
chose sur le fond mais qu'il exprime
autrement et là il aurait pu être dans
son rôle d'intellectuel c'est à dire
quelque chose
d'écrivain de complexité en tout cas
dire la même chose on pour autant
hystériser un débat qui est quand même
très complexe très complexe
la complexité du sujet c'est maintenant
il vous falloir il faut des censeurs
pour Houellebecq maintenant
sur l'ascension il me semble que c'était
publié donc il y a une ligne éditoriale
donc normalement
il a une évolution assez
je pense qu'on aurait pu anticiper qu'on
aurait pu anticiper les
retombées de telles propos et puis
pardon en même temps je pense que sur le
plan de du personnage est-ce que jamais
fait la même chose sur les réseaux
sociaux on aurait eu la même attitude
qu'elle aurait été la réaction des
réseaux sociaux parce qu'aujourd'hui on
a soit la censure soit les réseaux
ouverts à toutes les à toutes les
possibilités à toutes les folies à
toutes les expressions
c'est un peu le contraire des réseaux
sociaux je veux dire
en train de porter un jugement sur un
une expression qui était sur un extrait
dans un voilà probablement et dans un
domaine bien particulier qu'on aurait pu
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux qu'on
aurait peut-être analysé différemment ce
qui n'empêche pas non plus de penser
personnellement je pense que quand on
est quand on est médiatisé quand on est
un personnage médiatique médiatisé
reconnu etc on se doit d'être d'avoir
une forme d'exemplarité et on a le droit
de penser bien évidemment de dire tout
est et son contraire mais on doit aussi
penser ou retomber que ça peut avoir sur
les jeunes populations etc sur les sur
ceux qui vont s'accaparer cette pensée
qui vont qui vont l'amener beaucoup plus
loin que ce qui était peut-être envisagé
au départ et puis à général le son est
jamais très bonne donc je pense que de
toute façon là voilà et peut-être qu'il
faudrait s'interroger
oui bonjour je suis peut-être enfin je
remonte pas plus de générations etc donc
au fond c'est de dire je prends je fais
l'interprète des gens qui pensent ça
quoi mais c'est pas ce que je pense en
gros c'est ça qui qui dit aujourd'hui ce
qui fait que je suppose d'ailleurs le
vocabulaire des Français de souche qui
légitime ce qui dit juste après les
musulmans je trouve ça quand même assez
assez lourd de sens c'est pas
complètement déconnecté si je je mets
dans enfin je sais pas exactement si
c'était au même moment ou pas au même
moment mais deux expressions qui qui
vont bien ensemble quand même
ce que beaucoup de gens lui reprochent
c'est depuis soumission alors on lui
pardonne pas d'avoir écrit soumission
bon bah ok c'est est-ce que c'est est-ce
que ça fait un personnage du du
rassemblement national non je ne crois
pas on peut avoir un cri soumission tout
à fait
un public déjà très stigmatisé pour
plein de raisons économiquement
socialement enfin voilà et où c'est
compliqué même si on est troisième
génération enfin on est ici dans les
Yvelines on est à 50 ans en Yvelines on
sait très bien comment ça se passe dans
nos villes voilà comment je reçois ce
message d'un intellectuel qui finalement
légitime des choses moi c'est toujours
ça qui me gêne en fait pas de manière
générale oui ok de manière générale il y
a des gens qui le vivent au quotidien
donc
désinhibition insupportable concernant
les musulmans et l'islam je trouve que
c'est quand même pas tout à fait faux
quoi enfin et c'est vrai que c'est des
discours enfin alors après c'est bien de
dire les choses etc mais ça me rappelle
quand le peigne disait je dis tout ce
que les gens pensent tout bas mais s'il
le pense tout bas
c'est peut-être
que ça et c'est vrai qu'il y a quand
même une désinhibition du discours enfin
on l'a vu avec Zemmour
qui est quand même qui peut poser
problème
le discours qui semble poser problème à
beaucoup de gens alors après est-ce
qu'on peut dire et ben il faut pas qu'on
l'entende est-ce que est-ce que ne pas
l'entendre ça va le faire mourir non les
choses existent il faut par moment et
essayer de les accepter en tout cas les
entendre mais c'est pas en faisantaire à
Houellebecq alors attention parce que là
c'est pas assez policier dans nos
banlieues on va mal comprendre alors si
un intellectuel doit être obligé
complexe mais plutôt Marine Le Pen elle
n'avance pas j'ai rien contre moi Marine
Le Pen c'est juste qu'on parle de Front
national elle n'avance pas de manière
masquée
plusieurs personnes va être surpris des
propos qu'elle va tenir ou que des gens
aient lu avec elles vont tenir il y a
qu'à voir ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale à peine arrivé qui
rentrent chez eux enfin oui assume
exactement ce qu'ils sont un parti
xénophobe raciste etc quand c'est un
intellectuel
enfin encore une fois je pense que enfin
je rejoins ce que vous disiez c'est
qu'il y a quand même une responsabilité
ou alors on y va pas masquer on
revendique qu'on est effectivement
d'accord avec les théories XY sur
l'islamisme etc et donc quand on va lire
ou quand on va écouter on sait que c'est
quelqu'un qui revendique un nationalisme
exacerbé mais dans une case alors qu'il
arrête pas de s'exprimer qu'il a pas
besoin de dire voilà ils disent qu'ils
pensent dans chaque intervention il
écrit des livres pas tous remarquables
en tout cas tous intéressant donc
pourquoi vouloir tout de suite
l'ostraciser alors vous voulez pas qu'on
stigmatise les musulmans mais là il faut
stigmatiser ils doivent rester comme
écrivain ou est-ce qu'il doit avancer
comme voilà
en étant d'accord avec des thèses qui
sont soutenues par certains mouvements
elle est dans ce débat avec mon frère on
se doutait bien de ce qui allait sortir
enfin honnêtement ou alors il est
extrêmement nul je connais pas
Houellebecq j'ai pas vu ces bouquins
alors là je veux dire je suis très à
l'aise vraiment
j'imagine juste parce que je rappelle
juste parce que j'avais interview moi
j'ai juste après plateforme j'ai été le
le seul à avoir une autre question il
avait dit à un moment l'Islam est la
religion la plus con du monde et et il
avait c'était pas dans son livre il
avait dit dans la promotion de
plate-forme et et il avait été poursuivi
alors ils avaient poursuivi pour
incitation à la haine raciale ce qui
était totalement et donc il a été
relaxé parce que c'est c'est pas une
raciale c'était contre les musulmans
contre l'islames donc contre
l'islamation contre une religion mais il
avait été relaxé à ce moment-là il reste
plus que 3 minutes même pas on passe au
petit sujet de de face si vous voulez
bien bah parce que il y a aussi d'autres
choses quoi
[Musique]
alors bon on va parler privilégier le
président de la Fédération Française de
foot
je rappelle j'en ai rien à part rien à
cirer c'était pas comme édit de création
ce qu'il a dit fin de l'avenir de Zidane
enfin ça voulait dire ça ça vient
s'ajouter à tout un tas de comportements
des SMS un peu graveleux pas de le fait
que il n'est jamais pris en compte ou le
racisme ou l'homophobie qui peut avoir
lieu dans les dans les stades de
football qui a des affaires même de
pédophilie qui ont été un peu couvertes
etc bref
c'est le grand grand vilain il faut le
ministre des Sports
juste pour le grain
m'a fait il a eu le malheur de de ne pas
se prosterner devant l'icône Zidane
alors oui bon c'est sûr que
effectivement comme vous le disiez dans
certaines banlieues là il faut pas qu'il
aille promener là on a il a osé attaquer
il faudrait qu'il donne les deux
problèmes ce soir réellement ce qu'il a
pu dire sur Zidane je crois que ce qu'il
faut la difficulté avec Noël de Grace
c'est l'ensemble de son œuvre c'est ce
que vous rappeliez c'est que il y a
quand même tout un tas de choses qui ont
été censé c'est un naufrage des nouveaux
les il y a un peu ça quoi parce que ce
plutôt bon président de la ligue il a il
a repris la Fédération après l'Afrique
du Sud et il a monté puisque la France a
été championne du monde en 2018 je crois
pour un dirigeant français président de
la ligue dans les années 90 donc
voilà
championne du monde il y a 4 ans qu'il
fait finalise de de
dire
que j'aime bien qu'on s'occupe de
football voilà c'est pour ça
j'ai l'impression
on verra la justice jugera si
effectivement les plaintes sont
recevables etc j'aimerais que pour
l'instant pourquoi est-ce que lui
n'aurait pas le droit à la présomption
d'innocence avant d'être jugé s'il doit
être jugé toutes ces histoires sexuelles
il y a rien pour l'instant audit il y a
un audit sur la gestion
je vois s'exprime et ça va pas dans
votre sens alors là il faut surtout
revenir à la ligne de bois c'est à dire
que là le type d'isky pense de Zidane
alors c'est c'est horrible et puis s'il
avait fait 50 000 circonvolution pour
dire alors un certain joueur spécialiste
du coup de boule je n'en ai pas voulu
exetera alors là on a beau quelle belle
métaphore parce que Zidane venait faire
la dedans il renouvelle jusqu'en 2022
il Piaf comme un cheval avant d'entrer
dans l'écurie on le sait bien on sait
bien que Zidane voulait la place de
descendre donc quelque chose un sport
très populaire voilà fédération la plus
financée par l'État enfin non je suis
désolé cette personne a une
responsabilité dans son discrétion c'est
pas il vit pas comme ça dans dans l'air
du temps non il dit il est financé très
largement parce que c'est un sport
populaire et je pense qu'il doit donner
une forme d'exemple mais je suis autant
choqué quand il dit il y a pas de
problème
qui s'intéresse si peu au foot féminin
il a une responsabilité sociétale à un
moment donné dans la position qu'il a il
doit l'assumer je crois que son conseil
d'administration ou son CODIR la
convoquer dans les jours qui viennent
pour avoir des explications
[Applaudissements]
que il est relativement inamoble
le Comex et pourquoi il comment est-ce
qu'il va le délicieux absolument alors
les présidents League apparemment
peuvent se réunir en en commission
extraordinaire pour éventuellement
envisager son départ mais bon encore
faut-il que c'est encore faut-il que ça
se fasse ou absolument bah on en reparle
bientôt si vous êtes d'accord merci
merci à tous
va bien tout va bien merci à tous les
quatre et bon à très vite pour un
nouveau numéro de PAF
[Musique]